[Music]
i
have a story of a five-year-old
who used amazon's alexa to save his
mom's life
holy [ __ ] was she like alexa call the
police
yeah alexa 9-1-1 so actually
this little boy alexa how do i stop
choking
no oh how could you even say it if
you're trouble how do i stop someone
from choking
alexa teach me cpr now i wonder if that
would work everyone's alex is going off
by the way oh sorry alexa
hey google sorry hey siri hey siri hey
uh open trash hey echo echo
wait no that's the letter oh yeah that's
election what's the one nobody has
though
theory because we have yeah
we have everything but alexa yeah we do
actually anyway the point is here
that uh this five-year-old's grandma
the five-year-old's grandma had just
given them
an alexa or like programmed the alexa to
to call her when the grandson would say
like
oh hey alexa i want to speak to gigi
like that's what he calls his grandma
and then so so this one particular day
the mom who actually has been suffering
from
epilepsy her whole life she gets sleepy
she has seizures
um and so at this this was actually the
worst seizure she's ever gotten
and so the little boy couldn't wake up
her mom i mean his mom
and then so he ends up calling gigi his
grandma and then that's when he's
telling the grandma
like wake up yeah i can't wake up my mom
she's like oh [ __ ] better call the
police yeah because the grandma's an
hour
away so she couldn't like rush to them
no so
luckily um nobody was home well it was
just the two of them
yeah nobody where's the dad i don't know
i don't know is he an absent daddy or is
he in the military and he's far
just the two of us we can make it if we
try
just the two of us plus alexa yeah
you win alexa there's a modern twist on
it i see it it's just the two of us
she would probably die just the two of
us [ __ ] with alexa but dude that's
traumatizing for a five-year-old kid to
like not be able to wake up his mom
yeah he was crying when he called his
grandma so i'm gonna show you guys a
video
oh sad [ __ ] what okay let's go
what's that like i mean you just you
know all the info
here we go so this is the grandma here's
tyrion
and then here like tyrion lannister has
to be because
he's got to be what four five he was
named after tyrion lannister
know that it has to be come on i mean
come on
tyrion before tyrion no mister nobody
yeah
i never heard of the word tyrion the
word the name there's no way somebody
would just be like let me name my son
why not
tyrion is my favorite character tyrion
is the dopest character but without
being
a character yes he's a dope character
but i just think that that would be good
i've been drinking okay okay but what if
it's like darien but then like it's with
a t
are we really going to fix it on his
name guys
i just want to know if lannister's in
there maybe that's
lannister blank whatever the last name i
don't know
i really like arya as a name oh yeah i
do too as a casino i love the aria
it's beautiful it's so updated yep it
was probably one of my favorite casinos
i'm more of a win guy yeah i think win
is my favorite hands down but then the
uh it's too expensive are they by the
same company nope no
wayne is by mr wynn um by mr arya mr mrs
arya
you sexist owned by the mgm resorts
corporation
yeah mr and james can you believe a
woman
did it yeah owned by a lion
a lion a female lion let's watch this
video i miss
this interview with tyrion he got older
huh
he's five okay i thought he was laughing
or joking
and it turns out he was crying he told
me he couldn't wake his mom up
and so of course being her mom my uh
heart kind of fell to the ground there a
little bit and she
jumped scaring me the first thing i had
to do was you know
realize that he had my child's um
life in his hands so just because i'm an
hour away
um and so i told him what i was going to
do before i even did it which was called
9-1-1 alexa
car gg i just thought we're going to
tell me
hey grandma i love you hey gg i love you
um
a week later a week and a half later
he's calling because he can't wake his
mom up did you save mommy
yeah all of his inserts are so short
i know he was probably talking for like
30 minutes and they're like damn this is
how do you even make a sentence out of
it like this kid doesn't make any sense
and then i went um peter was at school
and wait and then they're like so did
your uh
did you save your grandma yes isaac
being that little because it was totally
like that
like the five-year-old conversations are
just like work you ask them a question
you'll be like what's your favorite food
um i like cooking i like cookie oh uh
rebecca was
uh she she had a chocolate and then she
didn't give it to me
and did you ever see a monkey
that actually makes way more sense than
whatever actual fiber other than the
inflection that's basically a joe
sentence
oh my god that's so true that's why i
could connect so well with children
sure we're on the same wavelength
brain power you know i live with uh
uh aunt's kids now basically and and so
leia's
super chatty right and then like every
time i walk into the house to like do
something like
laundry or whatever she can't wait to
just start talking to me
and half of the [ __ ] i don't know what
the [ __ ] she's saying yeah she'd just be
like
she does sound like that is so cute
that's what it sounds like
because she's presenting everything yeah
she's like me
fanny manny me and i just sit there and
go yeah yeah that's freaking awesome
dude
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
non-stop all day i'm just like folding
clothes and then she's like
a dinosaur
that's adorable but but if she if she
called me and then like something was
happening to ann or whatever i would
have just been like
what but the funny thing is the parents
understand everything that she's saying
yeah it'll be like yeah she wants you to
see the dinosaur book yeah
the [ __ ] how did you get that they hear
it all the time do you ever try talking
to her
right back here dude i'm gonna i should
go that back
i'm gonna do that next you should do
that you should do that for the rest of
the video yeah
yeah the whole video the rest of this
entire video she's so
cute no i thought this this story was
really interesting because
to think about it like now kids these
days they have technology that can
actually
save their lives and like save their
parents lives so the fact that
this kid was able to just be like hey
alexa call
gg you ever hear about the uh the kids
like just used to be on the news all the
time where like
the uh dad was like doing an oil change
and a [ __ ] car fell on them and then
like
a baby sees that [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] that not my daddy and then they
lift the car up
yeah and then the gut and then the dad
could get out the baby does it yeah
what the [ __ ] what news are you watching
what are we talking about look it up
it's like super power baby [ __ ] like
like super power baby [ __ ] lift car
like lifts car whatever all this is
zombies they usually be on the news all
the time they're like
i call [ __ ] uh big brother was
drowning
and then this toddler [ __ ] jumped in
grabbed
big brother [ __ ] pulled him out and
then he was like i'm gonna go back in my
crib
are we talking about taika here because
it was taika i believe that yeah
that would be the most watched video of
all time yes super power baby stuff
there's teens that have [ __ ] the teens
that's honest i remember a woman lifting
a car nah man
yeah it's usually about the moms the
moms are the ones that have superhero
strength it was baby [ __ ] i s
scary baby [ __ ] no i didn't write baby
[ __ ]
like the big brother underneath the toy
car and the baby's just like
i just i really want to see this though
baby
saves babies baby saves parents lives
parents
like i saw this on the news
and it turns up the article that is
huh it's sad it's sad dementia the
dementia joe has about this stuff
mainly babies are like toddlers calling
for medical
help whack i'm talking about superhuman
baby strength
where's the one that lifts the cars with
that opposable thumb where's the baby
that just [ __ ] does a goddamn
shoulder press and lifts the car yeah
this is in his diaper at the same time
this is an imagination
i think you saw the 1970s superman movie
i don't think joe imagined it
i think this is a conspiracy theory now
oh something happened
and joe is now placed into a different
timeline if you look at the christopher
reeves superman movie there isn't like
the mandela effect yes
exactly which is a child in this
christopher ryu superman movie who picks
up a truck
okay so maybe perhaps when i googled
baby lift's car i found that
superman so maybe he's conflating these
two things i don't know it's very sad to
see
it's quite a conflation it's just tragic
it's it's
devastates you he's gone
we have lost it you need johnny's help
absolute tragedy
i'm not gonna let this one go guys have
you okay he's looking for it
there is a concept on wikipedia called
hysterical strength
it is this is it it is a display of
extreme
strengths by human beyond what is
believed to be normal but not babies
though in life in
death situations example
okay
okay jack kirby claims a woman lifted a
car off her baby which inspired him to
create the
the idea hulk yeah oh really yeah but it
wasn't a baby it was it was the mom
yeah that's what i kept finding but
anyway oh well
you know what have you guys ever had to
call 911 hell yeah my friend overdosed
in my [ __ ] living room
i have actually you guys talk about this
i'm gonna find this i'm a petty [ __ ]
dude friend overdosed in your living
room yeah [ __ ] that
so we get to talk about his story yeah
we can try we can try
i'm uh i'm gonna get back to you guys on
this and have a rain check on this uh
fact check but i gotta tell you though
this [ __ ]
came over and then me and my um
she wasn't my girlfriend but we just
[ __ ] and then we were eating pizza
and he came over and he's like oh i just
um
got some stuff to party with and we're
like i'm eating a pizza i don't want to
[ __ ] snort anything
and then so he's uh he thought it was k
and he snorted it
finds out it's not what was it i don't
know what it was but he was overdosing
some ajax because we're watching
something and he just
got quiet and i look over and his face
was pale and his [ __ ]
head was locked back like that yeah so i
called 9-1-1 and then the cops came
and then do anything in the meantime i
ain't going to give him cpr that guy's
mouth was all [ __ ] up
i ate some pizza that had sex again
there you go he had foamy mouth [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
cops came that's scary and they were
they were heartless they slapped they
[ __ ] looked at him they grabbed his
face they slapped him they're like hey
what's wrong with your friend he doesn't
want to talk hey
and they were laughing at him yeah there
were some [ __ ] up people dude
it was nuts and then the uh paramedics
came and they're like what are you guys
doing get the hell out of here
the paramedics told the cops to leave
like they kicked the cops out because
they're like you guys aren't [ __ ]
helping and they were fighting and then
they stuck the thing in their mouth
in his mouth and he they uh got him back
to life yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] intense i've never heard
this story
i told it many times [ __ ] i don't have a
good memory and then um
during that time the cop was
interrogating me my mom everybody like
your mom was there yeah
what did your mom say she was sleeping
she she woke up to a [ __ ] nightmare
how old were you uh [ __ ] like
18 17. was your mom because you guys
ordered pizza and you didn't even offer
her anything
that's what she was most hysterical
about she was like oh my god
you know pepperoni is my favorite shape
you're [ __ ] yeah
that was crazy intense that's traumatic
it is what happened to your friend
afterwards
i don't know but i heard that uh right
now he's like a scientist and he's
developing drugs and stuff he's always
been passionate about drugs as you can
see
he's used his body as a [ __ ] guinea
pig and now he's developing different is
it for good
yeah he's really smart unless he's
making like bad drugs
[Music]
no he believes in experimenting and
having fun with drugs you know that's
his thing he believes in it
and then and then yeah he he does it
legally now he develops
different kinds of drugs i think i'm
most impressed that you're still friends
with this guy
i talk to him here and there but i never
see him that's impressive yeah
i have a lot of friends
[Music]
you